Adam: WE'RE STRANDED
ON A DESERTED ISLAND
WITH NOTHING
BUT SEVERAL MILES OF DUCT TAPE.
I'M FEELING PRETTY OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT OUR CHANCES FOR SURVIVAL.
[ DING! ]
Narrator:
ADAM GRABS SOME DUCT TAPE
AND SETS OFF TO TRY TO FIND
DRINKABLE WATER.
[ LAUGHS ]
CLEARLY, THESE PLANTS
ARE ALL GETTING
THEIR WATER FROM SOMEWHERE.
I JUST NEED TO FIND IT.
Narrator: BY FOLLOWING
THE LUSHER VEGETATION,
HE HOPES TO INCREASE HIS CHANCES
OF FINDING A WATER SOURCE,
BUT IT'S STILL
NO WALK IN THE PARK.
I'VE BEEN WALKING AROUND
FOR A WHILE...
[ BREATHING HEAVILY ]
...AND I STILL HAVEN'T FOUND
ANY WATER.
AND WHAT WE HAVE HERE
IS A CLASSIC CATCH-22.
[ SIGHS ]
I NEED WATER,
AND I'M BURNING THROUGH
A LOT OF IT
JUST TO TRY AND FIND WATER.
IF I DON'T FIND IT SOON,
IT'S GONNA BE BAD.
Narrator: SO, LET'S HOPE
JAMIE CAN DO BETTER.
Jamie: IT'S HOT OUT HERE,
AND I'M THIRSTY.
I GOT WATER EVERYWHERE
BUT NOT A DROP TO DRINK.
EXCEPT I CAN MAKE FRESH WATER
OUT OF THIS SALT WATER
WITH THE SUN'S HELP
AND SOME DUCT TAPE.
Narrator:
IT MAY SOUND AS THOUGH JAMIE'S
BEEN IN THE SUN TOO LONG...
Jamie:
IT'S ALREADY GETTING MOIST.
Narrator:
...BUT HIS "FRESH WATER
FROM SALT WATER" IDEA
IS ROOTED IN REALITY.
I FOUND WATER!
Narrator: HE'S GOING TO BUILD
A DEVICE CALLED A SOLAR STILL,
WHICH IS CONSIDERABLY
MORE COMPLICATED
THAN FINDING SALTY WATER
IN A SANDY HOLE.
Jamie: A SOLAR STILL USES
THE SUN'S RAYS AND CONDENSATION
TO COLLECT WATER AND HERE'S HOW.
THE HOLE I'VE DUG IS DEEP ENOUGH
THAT IT'S WET WITH SALT WATER.
AT THE BOTTOM,
I'LL PLACE A COLLECTION CUP
THAT I'VE MADE FROM DUCT TAPE,
AND ABOVE THE HOLE, I'M GONNA
PUT SOME CLEAR PLASTIC SHEETING.
THE HOT SUN SHINES THROUGH THAT
AND EVAPORATES THE WATER
FROM THE SAND,
LEAVING THE SALT BEHIND.
THE WATER VAPOR THEN CONDENSES
ON THE COOL INSIDE
OF THE PLASTIC SURFACE
AND DRIPS DOWN INTO THE CUP
AS PURE, DRINKABLE WATER.
THAT'S THE THEORY AT LEAST.
LET'S SEE HOW WELL IT WORKS.
Narrator:
WELL, HAVING MADE HIS WELL
AND TAPED UP A COLLECTION CUP...
Jamie: WELL, THERE IT IS.
GUARANTEE IT'S WATERPROOF.
Narrator: ...ALL THAT'S MISSING
IS THE CLEAR PLASTIC OVERSHOOT.
AND FOR THAT, JAMIE
IS BENDING THE DUCT-TAPE RULES.
Jamie: I'M MAKING A DUCT-TAPE
SPIDER WEB AS A FRAMEWORK
WITH WHICH TO HOLD TOGETHER
THIS STUFF -- SHRINK-WRAP.
NOW, I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
IT'S NOT DUCT TAPE,
SO WHY ARE WE USING IT?
WELL, IT DID COME
ON THE DUCT-TAPE PALLET.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M GONNA
USE THIS STUFF FOR,
BUT I BET YOU IT'S
GONNA COME IN REAL HANDY.
AND, YOU KNOW, IT'S SURVIVAL.
WE'VE GOT TO USE
EVERYTHING AT OUR DISPOSAL.
THE THING IS
THAT ALL THESE LITTLE PIECES
DON'T REALLY HELP US SO MUCH,
BUT ONCE THEY'RE HELD TOGETHER
INTO ONE BIG SHEET,
WE'RE GOLDEN.
THERE WE GO.
HOPEFULLY, I DIDN'T
USE MORE WATER MAKING IT
THAN IT'LL MAKE FOR ME.
[ LAUGHS ]
Narrator: THE LAST STEP IS
TO CAREFULLY POSITION THE SHEET
OVER THE HOLE.
THERE WE GO. THAT'S THE TICKET.
Narrator:
AND ALMOST IMMEDIATELY,
THERE ARE ENCOURAGING SIGNS.
ALL THAT FOG
THAT YOU CAN ALREADY SEE
FORMING ON THE UNDERSIDE
OF THE PLASTIC
IS WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT.
IT'S PICKING UP THE MOISTURE
FROM THE DAMP SAND,
WHICH IS EVAPORATING,
COLLECTING ON THE PLASTIC,
AND EVENTUALLY, THOSE WILL FORM
LARGER AND LARGER DROPLETS,
WHICH WILL RUN DOWNHILL
INTO MY COLLECTION CONTAINER.
NOW WE JUST HAVE TO WAIT.
Narrator:
IT'S THE MOMENT OF TRUTH -- TWO
HOURS COOKING IN THE MIDDAY SUN.
WHAT'S THE VERDICT?
[ SIGHS ]
WELL, THERE IT IS.
THAT'S PURE WATER,
BUT THAT'S LIKE 1/4 OF A CUP.
WITH LESS THAN 5%
OF THEIR DAILY WATERY NEEDS,
IT'S A DISAPPOINTING RESULT.
Jamie: WHY DOES EVERYTHING
HAVE TO BE SO DIFFICULT?
Narrator: BUT BACK
AT THE RUMBLE IN THE JUNGLE,
ADAM'S WELLING UP
WITH EXCITEMENT.
MM! IT'S FRESH!
ALL RIGHT, WATER BOTTLES.
HALF MY TASK IS DONE.
I HAVE FOUND FRESH WATER,
NO SMALL FEAT,
AND THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR OUR SURVIVAL.
NOW I SIMPLY
HAVE TO GET IT BACK.
Narrator: THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT AS EASY AS IT SOUNDS.
I WOULD KILL FOR A WORKBENCH
RIGHT ABOUT NOW.
Narrator: ADAM'S MAKING
A KIND OF TUBULAR BOTTLE
THAT SHOULD HOLD
ABOUT 10 PINTS OF WATER,
PROVIDED, OF COURSE,
THAT IT DOESN'T LEAK.
IF I GET A SINGLE WRINKLE
IN THIS SEAM,
IT'S A PLACE WHERE WATER
CAN GET OUT -- CAN'T HAVE THAT.
WATER'S GOT TO GO FROM THE POND
INTO HERE INTO HERE.
Narrator:
IT'S A PAINSTAKING OPERATION,
BUT EVENTUALLY,
THERE'S ONLY ONE THING
LEFT TO DO.
OH! OH! OH!
IT'S COLD!
Narrator: FILL IT UP.
FILL UP, BABY.
COME ON!
PLEASE HOLD UP.
FIRST IMPRESSIONS ARE GOOD.
[ LAUGHING ]
IT'S WORKING!
Narrator: AND SECOND IMPRESSIONS
ARE EVEN BETTER.
IT SEEMS TO BE HOLDING!
[ LAUGHS ]